[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time
[Applause]
I'm link and I'm red this week at the
oval table
of it's kind of a mix of outdoor and
indoor lighting it's very nice
we're going to be answering questions
that we've never answered before that we
asked you to ask us and I believe that
we have the people who ask those
questions present
oh uh-huh right there
so
we we actually haven't we haven't talked
a whole lot yeah you know because we're
like we're moving around we're going
from thing to thing
getting ready for the next thing how's
your uh how's it how's your mythicon
Brett uh well I just took some Pepto
um I mean I'm doing great
I also just took some peppers yeah I saw
that I I went up to Jenna and uh she was
in kind of a group of people I leaned in
and said can you give me some Pepto
what's happening for you down there well
hopefully nothing and that's uh that's
why I took Pepto
but then you know when you see somebody
taking pills do you just that's not a
good habit just when you see somebody
taking pills they didn't say well can I
have some of those pills
because that's what happened well
when when I saw that you were chewing it
I was like oh it's a chewable yeah
well that's really my jam do you have a
thing uh you know I love to chew
well but also you have a thing where you
don't really know uh when a pill is a
chewable or a what's the alternative
swallow swallowable swallowable yeah and
I've tried to explain this that
typically the flat discs are chewable
and the capsules are swallowable right
but I don't you can I'm pretty sure you
can chew everything
if you try hard enough yeah like I mean
if when it goes to your stomach it's
like
if your stomach chews it
I don't know I feel like I feel like I'm
really getting the most out of whatever
I'm consuming if I actually chew it
that's why I chew pudding
[Applause]
but no I mean I can see that you're
concerned about my stomach but it's
totally fine and links is very much fine
I think he's just taking preventative
Pepto-Bismol at this point it's great a
little bit doesn't hurt and I think it
makes your poops like
really dark purple yeah real dark makes
your tongue dark it's like the color of
your jacket hey later on tonight on our
main stage show we can both stick out
our black tongues because that's what
happens when you put that bismuth
whatever the active ingredient is no no
no not yet you got to wait okay
congrats on the show last night James
and the shame was awesome
that was a lot of fun almost too much
fun all at once too early
you seemed like you were having the time
of your life having the time of my life
Jesse was having the time of her life
too yes she was
I was watching from that vantage point
over there for a little bit and I was
like well I don't want to I don't want
to be a distraction
I went away
and then I came back later
to to give approving nods of your
performance
I felt those you know but somehow just
based on what Charles said at the
beginning of your podcast
it feels like me and Charles are in a
little bit of a competition I mean I I
don't feel like I started it but he was
talking about he didn't want to show me
up and he didn't want me to show him up
right right yeah he kind of stole your
thunder when he made an appearance and
everyone was cheering for him not you
well but I do want you to know just to
be prepared today for the next hour or
so I don't have any barbecue sauce
um I'm not gonna do any dancing
demonstrations man he got Nancy up there
I love that pretty great
pretty great yeah is that just like a
thrill a typical Friday night for them I
think so yeah I love it
seemed like it seemed very automatic for
them didn't it
you want to answer some of these
questions that we've never answered
before let's get to some questions
you want me to you want me to read it so
what we'll do is we got a microphone
down here we think that everyone who has
a question is present we'll just ask it
and then we may ask you why'd you ask
that question Bonnie Stewart
right here he's right here we're gonna
bring a mic to you Bonnie but I'm gonna
read your question while the mic is
coming to you
um so Bonnie asks if you were a ghost
what location item or person would you
haunt
do you have life insurance taken out on
each other yeah
that's kind of like a hard left turn in
the middle of this well I I can see I
can see how those might be related
you're gonna die who do you want to uh
haunt and does the other person benefit
from your death is basically
the two-part question am I reading this
right Bonnie yes I mean basically I I
like ghosts so I have to ask and then
also I work in entertainment production
and it's something my husband and I've
always discussed is like I wonder if
they do that I figure you have to but
I'm just curious okay well let's start
with the Ghost part you seem like a
demented person
[Applause]
you're in the right place
if you were a ghost what location item
or person would you haunt
well
I mean first of all
I think the most strategic thing uh
would be haunting you
right because I feel like it would be a
way for you to like continue to have a
vibrant career right you could like lean
into my ear and say
that one's not chewable
no I'm just saying that I mean oh that
one is chewable
yeah I mean I would definitely do that I
would give you advice but I'm just
saying that if you didn't want to have
to rethink everything it would be
simpler for you if we just continue to
be a Duo but I was a ghost kind of like
that Smosh movie Ghost mates remember
that basically we would just be
following the plot of ghost mates right
uh so T-Pain is now involved in this uh
hopefully yeah
um
would people see you you're not visible
so I would just seem very very fixated
on your
you know your memory I think I would
function like a typical ghost which is I
don't know if it's real or not and
that's what a lot of people would think
about you I think I would just call you
like
my imaginary friend
okay which is not far from reality right
I imagine that you're my friend right
now
I don't know how to feel about that
I mean do you imagine that I'm your
friend uh I mean I think I believe that
you're my friendly
right so but if you were to think about
it in an abstract way you'd be imagining
our friendship and doesn't that make me
your imaginary friends okay technically
yes
yeah we can be each other's imaginary
friend dude but who would you it could
be a new
aspect of our relationship
okay we can talk about that later
whether or not we will become each
other's Imaginary Friends
uh I know that you really like scaring
people oh I love it so you're really I
hate your question
because I don't like being scared and I
I get I get afraid if I need to scare
somebody
so it's like I would just be the worst
ghost I think I would definitely have to
possess somebody
is that an option uh demons can do that
oh demon ghost you want to be a demon
yeah different yeah I'd rather be a
demon
I do think it would be fun though again
I don't really know what I believe about
this but if I died and was suddenly a
ghost and I was like oh that is a real
thing I think I would haunt like a very
popular atheist like Richard Dawkins
Richard Dawkins hell until he like
breaks down he's like all right they're
real
my life's work it's ruined
and then you're like it's just me Rhett
that guy from the internet yeah
it started out as a hypothetical
question in a live ear biscuit right
um I don't know why I'm using that voice
is that the voice you would use no
I probably keep my own voice I mean but
it would be more ghostly right like tell
me to choose something
no I'm not gonna I know you're not my
puppet no I'm not gonna you can imagine
that I did that
you're not as Cooperative as my dad
right
um okay second part of your question yes
we did have an awkward conversation with
um the people who help us make these
decisions about insurance and such and
we do have
an insurance policy on one another which
is
pretty wild right think about it I mean
because you get to a certain point
you're like well
what
do we do if like one of us kicks the
bucket or when one of us kicks the
bucket and if it's sooner I think the
other person gets more money I don't
know is that how I I can't remember do
we have it on us let's read the life
insurance yeah I don't have it
like there's yeah so if it's it's if one
of us is there anything wrong with
talking about the specifics of this well
only of course not nothing other than
the fact that you will almost definitely
be wrong about it
uh other than that yeah it's totally
fine I mean there was it was probably
like 40 pages and then you just get to a
point where you're just signing it and
saying okay this is something about if I
die
Christy takes over from me
Christy or she just gets the money that
I would get based on the contract that I
and you got to keep doing stuff based on
the contract that I read Christy might
want you to die
haha
it's not I I have I have a lot very
pretty yeah
that's how we designed it like yeah it's
got to be some silver lining well it
would be really sad if one of us dies
but at least it's like good gosh now
look at all this money here's the thing
we talked about this on the way over
here and we made sure not to tell
Christy about this because we flew
separately so
link and I and Jesse were on
uh and Stevie as well we're all on the
same flight over here and then Christy
came with Shepard uh in Lando and
Lincoln later right we didn't want to
miss school and I was like what if this
plane goes down
laughs
she said welcome to my world the reason
we didn't bring you you're always
thinking we didn't want you to think
about this but basically what would
happen and this is what we talked about
was Christy would just be in charge
she said that's right baby
and then uh very quickly it turned into
uh that Christy was going to do
something uh with Cass with Cassie
Stevie's girlfriend it was going to be
the the Christie and Cassie show and we
thought that that would be that would be
great pretty awesome
okay
yeah so what I mean but so there you go
to answer your question we literally had
to think through all the scenarios like
well if one of us dies what if both of
us die one of our
we figured it all out
we're totally ready
to die ready for it and haunt Richard
Dawkins
just like the Biggie Smalls album
okay next question is from Jasmine Lopez
where's Jasmine oh right here see okay I
love this question Jeff nice hat Jazz
can I call you jazz jazz jazz smooth
like jazz I could call you Jazzy but
that's what I call my dog
Jazzy Jeff DJ Jazzy Jeff Probst
call him that
Jasmine says my man and I broke up who
gets to keep you
oh him that introduced me to you all or
me that fell in love from the second
episode I watched oh oh wow okay first
of all you're here he's not exactly so
and the tickets were his birthday gift
but since we stopped talking I'm here
so I thought that you would take a
special interest in this because
um I'm very interested in this
you have a tendency I've observed to
believe that if someone is into
something someone else close to them
cannot also be into that one of the best
examples of this and the earliest
example of this was when your stepsister
Emmy just liked music
so you decided you're like I can't like
music
she's taking music from me right it's a
whole vertical of music not a genre all
music I remember it like it was
yesterday when my mom told me that
he said now
link
Jimmy and I are we're getting a divorce
and you're still going to be my son
she didn't say that
and the first thing I remember saying
was oh thank God I can like music again
I won't be related to that stepsister of
mine
and that's and and now I love music so
it's like a lot of good can come from a
really proper divorce right
right
you know what you just you know you just
you know sometimes
sometimes life gives you lemons
and
I just threw them make orange juice and
let the world wonder how you did it
you know what I'm saying okay what's
your perspective on that jazz
on the lemons
[Laughter]
just on I mean it seems like
embedded in this question is the same
principle that you feel like you both
can't go on liking Us in the same way
no because he looks exactly like you so
yeah
well then why'd you break up
foreign
[Applause]
she saw the life insurance policy
like that okay well this has gotten very
complicated all of a sudden
so it seems like you can you each choose
one of us yeah and only watch like like
you only watch
like half of the screen do you want to
watch red or do you want to just watch
me because you want to watch me because
you're over him yeah I understand that I
mean we did think for a while about
selling some sort of um device that you
could place over one half of the screen
but then we realized that's just paper
yeah and uh mythical.com buy paper so
you can cover up the one you don't like
as much but you know interestingly what
we could do to make that even easier and
I don't want to you know sign our team
up for any unnecessary work but there
could be like like we never do that
always
yeah that's one of the things that
happens when we talk is that we end up
giving work to People by accident right
Stevie had to come up with crabs inside
of crabs last night she's got to figure
out what that means right
um but the uh I think maybe some sort of
filter
uh that just edits one of us out
completely of an episode I think I think
you should do the same thing that we
tell everybody to do when they complain
about not being able to play along with
the games just put your hand over the
answer
right yeah put your hand over the answer
read it
is Reddit here today
is Reddit represented okay
all right
yeah
what this guy's got an idea
right he introduced her
and then she started from the second
episode oh yeah why not the first
episode
the second episode was on my own the
first one was together with him and I
was like okay that's potential and then
it came out in my YouTube list and here
I am now okay so you just feel like you
got the what you needed out of that
relationship right and now we're getting
Twice The Views so
exactly all the welcome here just you
know just
just agree to not talk to each other
and see you over the Internet yeah thing
yeah
Matt Walker
right here okay we've moved these people
to the front hey Matt hey how's it going
great now on a scale of one to five how
intelligent do you think your question
is zero
yeah off the charts just so long as
we're clear right yeah
Matt asked us do you think you could
survive for an entire year only eating
five pound Velveeta cheese blocks
[Laughter]
[Music]
follow-up question just how thick do you
think your blood would get
okay Matt I have a question for you sure
are you preparing for some sort of
challenge
[Laughter]
no I can give some backstory if you want
okay um so at work we work in a room
with no phones we get very bored uh and
come up with the strangest questions
that we can think of so this is just to
pass the time
um and we we figured that out so you
said that you work in a room with no
phone we do so you get bored yeah
just the White House what are you
talking about
oh you're not going to tell us I can't
I'd have to kill you okay
and take out that life insurance policy
there's a life insurance joke in there
somewhere
okay
um
why do you think we can answer this town
Velveeta cheese blocks it turns out
that's the biggest block you can buy and
we calculated that if you buy one a day
and eat that whole thing it's about
forty five thousand dollars a year of
just Velveeta
okay so you've got the budget covered
right let's talk about the health impact
that's the follow-up question 45 000. do
you have to eat all five pounds every
day that's a lesson challenge I guess uh
well that's not going to work okay yeah
I mean all you can have is Velveeta
cheese which is not even really a cheese
it's probably a cheese product right
right
mostly Plastic Man it'd be a rough year
first of all I can guarantee you that
yeah I think it would it would come to a
halt
pretty quick the whole the inner
workings can you drink water or do you
get the moisture there's water in it
there's water in it
you got all your moisture from the
cheese if you squeeze a block of
Velveeta you get
cheese water a five pound block yeah
that's important yes you're drinking
cheese water eating cheese
hey and there's a thing I I you know
Christy is a cheese lover
you're a cheese lover I Christy got me
cheese for my birthday I like cheese but
I just don't understand I think it's
something to hear Chris he talks about
it is like there's something that
happens in her like loins
well I don't want to get I don't want to
say anything inappropriate about your
wife while she's just behind you in my
line of sight she's not in my line of
sight like this this is all on purpose
but I do believe that the same thing
that happens in your brain during sexual
stimulation happens in your brain while
consuming cheese and chocolate
[Applause]
so this might be something you need to
look into
why you know I I'm I like to stay
hydrated
and so that's my thing yeah like through
through all intimate exercises I've
heard that now if she wants if I want
I'm gonna serve her I guess pizza and
Velveeta
yeah I've heard that you're known to
take a water break in the middle of a
encounter
yeah yeah yeah maybe you can start
taking a Velveeta break
you did you just keep a block of cheese
next to the bed I mean that's a big
block of cheese I think that might count
as like a threesome at that yeah oh gosh
a cheese some something just how thick
do you think your blood would get
you would die yes it's not it's not a
good idea but I do think we should try
it and I think you should start a
YouTube channel
I'll send you the link okay
do not do that Matt Walker
where you want to go now you want to go
here yeah uh
is this Evie or EV field EV Fields hello
EV okay this is uh this is a multi-part
question here now we all know that there
will come a day when you retire and stop
creating content but if everything were
to disappear besides the merch and the
memories you've left on people what kind
of impact or Legacy do you think you
would have left in that hypothetical
situation
that's interesting
but hypothetical
because how would that ever happen yeah
because we think about and we've talked
about on this show before just this
Reams and reams of content over you know
like 16 we're looking 20 years
eventually it'll be more than that so
much of our lives are on the internet I
mean just look at ear biscuits alone and
we've talked about how much is there I
I take strange comfort in that and now
that you've taken that away from me
thank you
hypothetically yeah the merch on its own
we got we got some good merch and we got
a lot of merch too like
we've said a lot of things on t-shirts
but I don't know what people would
conclude if they only had the merch
they'd be like were they NASCAR drivers
one of them was a snake like there's
just
right there's just so many can yeah
we're still good there's a lot of
different conclusions rub some bacon on
it that's an old shirt that was one of
our First Merch items
yeah it still works
the technique still works rubbing bacon
on things
boil for safety there's just a lot of
things that out of context wouldn't make
a lot of sense
at all now if you got if you got hold of
the book of mythicality that would that
would explain a lot that would help but
that feels like cheating at that point
right so let's just say that doesn't
exist I just like like he's got the feel
good
Mythical Morning shirt on you know what
I think that even through our merch
there would there would be this message
of
feel good accept yourself accept others
and let's be nicer to people yeah you
know
um
I do think that
a lot of the slogans that we put out
into the world are things that like come
from our mouths and our conversations
but they also are just a great
indication of the relationship we have
with mythical beasts that you know it's
we can't it's it's we kind of feed each
other in that energy right like the you
gather the people that have similar
energy and I you know I'm just glad that
uh you know when we meet you guys at the
meet and greet lines or see your faces
here
uh and we just we soak up your energy
that there's so much positivity there's
so much uh acceptance and a welcoming
vibe that like every everybody doesn't
look the same everybody's everybody
doesn't is not into all the same stuff
like it you know there's it's an
Eclectic group but you have this you
have this um now if you keep yelling I
cannot keep a train of thought yeah
all right get kicked up did you kick
that person out you are not accepted
you're judged
you know what I was trying to say yeah
well I think that's my favorite my
favorite thing about being here is that
there's a group of people who they get
all of the inside jokes and all of the
references you know right because it's
one thing like when you've got a friend
and you know somebody like in your town
or whatever that's like another mythical
beast but
I assume and I can kind of see it on
your face is that being in the presence
of other mythical beasts in this way
where it's like this unspoken thing is
pretty cool
[Applause]
literally the coolest thing ever for
like amazing and this isn't the first
thing I've ever seen with you guys so
like I just threw myself right into this
welcome 10 out of 10. 10 out of 10. well
I told Jesse you know we you know
because she was she hasn't performed in
quite some time you wouldn't know that
based on how she did last night
but I kept telling her I was like you
have nothing to worry about this is the
warmest group of people that you will
ever imagine like we could literally get
out there and just like
bomb so hard and they would tell us that
we did a great job
[Applause]
you guys have given me is so much more
than just the content
um I'm not trying to get sappy here but
I wouldn't have do it okay
okay look I would not have come out as
transgender if it wasn't for you guys
you have
you have made such a safe and welcoming
place I have never felt more accepted
and loved here and you guys just exuded
that and for me the reason I asked this
is because your impact is so much more
than just the surface content I mean yes
you're eating crabs inside of crabs
which some might say is not the highest
quality content out there but just
just the way you embrace the weirdness
and all of us and also on ear biscuits
just being so open about your guys's
stories and your own histories and
Journeys just help someone like me be
like you know feel comfortable with
actually being curious about themselves
and exploring that so just
you guys are great for that and I really
thank you for just the positivity and
love
thank you for sharing that
thanks EV now
yeah that's that means a lot to us
and I want to go back to the beginning
of that question was about
retirement right retirement you're
talking about retirement let's talk
about that for a minute
um you know we're at an interesting
point in our careers right now you know
it's
we there's a lot of opportunity and
honestly there's a lot of different
directions that we could take mythical
in and
but you know because and I think a lot
of it has to do with being
[Music]
middle-aged you know who are you talking
about I mean yeah you you you're you're
you've broken the 45 barrier I think
that's past middle aged I think is it
see for you you're past middle age
and you just start to think about like
all right the future you think about
like
um by the time we're 50 in our early 50s
then it's where you know the kids are
going to be out of both of our homes you
think about like
but is there do we have the ability to
retire at some point
like earlier than most people
conceivably we also have the ability to
like I was saying take the direction of
mythical in a lot of different ways
we're trying a lot of things that aren't
that aren't just about
um the content we create but like
there's a whole business side of running
uh mythical and saying all right what
are what are the initiatives that we
want to invest in you know one example
the mythical Creator accelerator
you may be familiar with that we invest
in up-and-coming creators who are
building their own brand and we want to
be footsteps that they can follow in
when our experience was we really didn't
have
anyone to emulate so we saw that as an
opportunity it's a business opportunity
it's a legacy play for us to say how do
we invest in up and coming creators help
them benefit and build their brands it's
totally separate from mythical but by
using you know with our guidepost so
they can be healthy and Thrive and put
their own version of good out into the
world that's very exciting
but it's separate from
our own work as creators so at times we
find ourselves
um
being pulled in many directions or seen
that our company can be pulled pushed or
sent
in all types of directions and I think
and these are conversations that
honestly
we've we've been having right given
given where we're at in our careers I
think so it's kind of the balance
between
running a business and starting new
lines of business as we continue to to
grow mythical
and then remembering that we are
creators first and foremost and
sometimes it's just difficult to do both
of those things I think the thing that
we're excited about that we really
haven't talked about at all you'll be
the first to hear about this is that
we're really seeing 2023 as a
reinvestment in us as creators
um and
you may be like well you already make so
much stuff but I think that in terms of
some of those uh maybe if you've been
watching for a long time and some of
those early videos that got you into the
mythical world that uh maybe leaned a
little bit more into US expressing
ourselves creatively that's something
that we really want to press on in in
2023 so
but I think that as we think about
retirement in general the
the way I've thought about this is
even if we were to say okay we're going
to retire and
um uh I'm gonna go live in a little
cabin with Jesse you're invited Jesse
um oh how nice of you and I think you're
the one who might need an invitation and
and then I'm gonna just do woodworking
non-stop the problem regardless of what
decision we made individually as what we
wanted to do in retirement
there's no doubt in my mind that we'd be
trying to find a way to turn that into
content because we can't help ourselves
right and also turning it if like if I
had a cabin somewhere in an undisclosed
location and you had a cabin I don't
know if you want a cabin or what what
you want whatever you want your version
of a cabin
um yeah you really put me on the spot
but sure I'd like for it to be really
modern the van is what people are saying
yeah I'll park my van at my Ultra Modern
cabin
but even in that scenario there would be
some way that I like having a toilet
that's not in my shower okay good I
agree with that we would have there
would still be content you know right it
would be like hey we got to do our
podcast
go to go to the spot in your van where
you do the podcast I'll go to the spot
in my cabin because I think it it will
be I want to do that right not well we
got to do that well you think when you
think about retirement you think about
being able to
begin to pursue what you want to do and
what your passions are if you're lucky
enough to to do that and I think that
we're just privileged to be doing what
we want to do already already and there
may be some things that uh aren't as fun
you know it's not as fun to run a
company as it is to make content uh so I
think the thing that is always going to
be there is going to be making content
yeah I think that
that's a lot of the soul-searching that
we've been doing recently has and
conversations that we've been having
but what do we really what are the next
five years ten years look like for us I
mean we're we we are specifically having
those conversations and
the thing that really invigorated the
conversation and this like it kind of
felt like a light bulb moment and it's
it's what you just said that like we
find ourselves in this amazing position
to
have the opportunity to express
ourselves because
of all of you you know it's like without
an audience you
can't make things in a vacuum and the
fact that there's so much
enthusiasm and Trust uh and excitement
for what for what we want to do and how
we want to connect with each other and
connect with you guys that that gives us
a good amount of Freedom right and
saying
we can we can take even more advantage
of the creative freedom that we have now
by cooking up even more things that we
can share you know
um as opposed to working on things in
private and in secret and then hoping to
develop them by playing somebody else's
game and then no one ever seen it yeah
we've done a good amount we've talked
about that we did the whole year biscuit
where we talked about all the ideas that
we have come up with and all the movie
ideas and TV show ideas and you know for
years we've taken a pretty big part of
ourselves creatively and tried to
package it in a way that we could drive
across town
uh and have a meeting with a group of
important people and trying to talk them
into letting us make something and after
so many years of doing that and just
repeatedly being told that uh this
doesn't work or even when it does work
and they want to do it they want to put
their spin on it in a way that makes it
not what we wanted to make
we're beginning to be like okay stop
trying to convince those people to let
us make something and just start making
stuff for you guys directly
so
we got to figure out you know how that
looks and how we do that as a company
but that's that's where our minds are at
right now yeah and so you see what
happens when the word retirement enters
our brain and then it comes out as how
do we express ourselves you know I think
that's exactly how we think about
retirement is that we don't I guess
and in that sense
um but we do think about cabins I guess
yeah yeah maybe we do mine's gonna be
rustic
okay
uh Jessenia
all right your question
sorry what is it Justin yeah
what emotion do you both feel the most
oh
what emotion do we
each feel the most or both feel the most
my theory is that it's the same emotion
but I'll let you go first
um
oh gosh this is
um
Chrissy and I just went on a little
getaway
into uh we went back to Big Sur and you
know you get you lose reception so you
got to be you got to be strategic about
like downloading what you want to listen
to and we downloaded
um the audiobook brene Brown's book uh
atlas of the heart
I highly recommend this book even though
uh I only listened to the first two
chapters so far
usually that's all you need pretty
awesome so far but she takes you through
all the all the emotions that can exist
I'm like wow there's so many emotions
that I I didn't know I could have
and it's you know she She lays the
groundwork that like it's really
important
it it opens up your life to be in touch
with your emotions and to be able to
identify more of them specifically kind
of it it gives you a vocabulary with
which to understand your own experience
and there by live a more robust
experience you know if you just think
well I can just
I just feel anxious or I just feel
sometimes I realize that anxiety is
actually anger or like if I say I'm
frustrated it's like well that actually
may be anger but and then I
but then also saying hey there's there's
lots of different types of there's
there's there's joy you can experience
there's lots of positive emotions too
that's what I'm trying to say
I want to experience all of the emotions
but what's my so that's my
recommendation I don't know if it's my
wreck today but atlas of the heart
yeah that should be the wreck so I don't
know
um
I think
like
I don't wanna I don't want to just go to
anxiety
that's that's definitely me yeah well
just listen just be honest but I think
that that's probably
that's probably that's probably my go-to
yeah
pretty good I gotta I got a pretty good
anxious Sweet Spot there it's just like
Nestle right down in there it's like
like that divot in your bed where you're
like oh this is where I lay every single
night and I can tell if I shift over two
inches
in the wrong way you know it's like oh
I'm back in that
anxious spot again maybe I should roll
over
roll over into Joy
roll over to Joy that's your book link
okay
bro roll over into Joy roll over into
Joy yeah okay I'd read that I'd read the
first two chapters
um
is Goosebumps an emotion
yeah potentially but so I I totally
appreciate what you're saying and that's
something that therapy has helped me
with is like
um
you feel something and then you are if
you lean into it and you get to the
bottom of what is that oh there's
something beneath it but generally
speaking and this may be this is I kind
of figured that's what your answer would
be and it may be surprising maybe even
surprising to you but I think that as
you as you look at a list of emotions
I think that anxiety is probably the
thing that is operating the most often
for me as well now I may like deal with
it or it may manifest itself differently
and people may not be like
um oh I wouldn't have you may not know
that even if you're interacting with me
I don't tend to like let you know that
that's what's happening but I was
thinking about the way that I interact
with this this weekend right yeah you
know
one huge part of it is anticipation and
just knowing that we're gonna we've
thought about creating this experience
for you guys that we you know we we've
got a team that knows you really well
and knows what you like and what you
want and picking a special spot like
this but then
right on the other side of every one of
those anticipations is an anxiety about
something that could go wrong right is
the ferris wheel going to come down and
just roll through the whole town
just taking people one by one and
throwing them
you know
uh and then you're like oh we made a
decision to do this outdoor event was
that a mistake is it going to rain yes
it's gonna rain on day one
um and then things like okay uh the
performance last I'm like choosing where
am I going to place my worry it's like
okay I'm going to do this uh concert
perform these songs that I've never
performed for a crowd you really want to
kind of have warmed up a little bit in
front of like some people but I don't
have time to do that so let's do oh
it'll be fine let's just do it you know
Jesse's got anxiety about it
um and then there's just all the things
and then we've got this ridiculous show
that we're gonna do tonight where we're
only doing the things that we're going
to do because it's you guys and we know
that you'll have a fun time watching us
do something that we probably wouldn't
take out on the road
[Applause]
but yeah so it's like
a lot of you know and I don't
necessarily think I would call it a uh
an anxiety disorder but it is definitely
the general thing that's always there
just under the surface that you can dip
into at any point to be like okay yep
these that's that's something I can
attach some energy to right now and
worry and try to figure out okay I'm
going to change my answer to horny okay
I don't believe that's an emotion you
might want to talk to your therapist
about that
um it's like saying that your love
language is sex which I tried to pull
that one time
uh yeah oh really it's not yep you can't
it can't be it's not an emotion it could
be physical touch but yeah not always
that kind of physical touch
okay but then I'll just go with uh
Goosebumps okay
how are you I feel like I'm I don't I
feel like I've been pretty chill here no
I yeah and I think uh Jesse and I were
talking about it last night how chill I
am yeah how chill link is
the
because the thing that you want to be
able to do is and I feel like with each
year
that I get older I get better at this
is
not just wanting something to be over
right there's so much in my life when I
had something like that performance last
night or what are you doing tonight
where I'm just I'm actually sort of
fantasizing about getting to my hotel
room and lying down
right no and you try and they probably
don't want to hear that yeah right
because just get through it don't screw
it up and just get to your hotel bed but
that but you're but you're you're
acknowledging like that's something's
wrong with that yeah and I actually the
well and
being able to talk to Jesse throughout
the past months yeah about her being a
part of this actually was helpful like
being able to tell her some of those
things that I would tell myself was
therapeutic for me because I was like
listen
the experience is going to be when it's
happening like don't let that slip by
like anticipate it look forward to it
and then enjoy it when it's happening
and I think that by talking about that
so much I actually when it was over I
didn't have a sense of relief I was like
oh man
I'd like to do that again or I'd like I
wish that had gone on longer I wish that
was still happening you know
that's good yeah so I'm getting better
at that so you didn't run to your bed
right afterward well we did run to the
bed
oh
what are we learning here
yeah we've we've had the
privilege of experiencing so many things
like
it's we've we lead a really wild life
being able to like just like live our
dreams and but yeah there's something to
like we wrote about in the book you like
making a decision to stop and celebrate
you know and say like this moment I'm
here for it I'm in it you know yeah and
I you know I I just want to go back to
giving you guys credit that like you're
you're you're you create you've created
an environment for us here that like I'm
not freaking out but instead I'm like
the they know what they're here for and
they know what they're going to get so I
just let's just let's just go with it
you know it's you can't you might as
well not try too hard just just let it
happen
let it happen it's a safe space so
I do feel
like
I'm I'm I'm living it up
yeah I feel like I'm having a good time
I'm having a good time and I it's it's
so much
um it's so much different when you go
into a place
where you're having to
explain yourself or prove yourself it's
like right so that's what I was talking
to Jesse I was like this weekend is
built on
you know for some of you it may be days
or weeks or months but many of you years
of a relationship you know that we get
to come in here and have together for a
weekend and experience in in person
Jamie how we doing on time we got when
are we supposed to be done
I think we're just rolling right along
we're good oh we're good so uh Mike
Davis
right there in the leopard print
how you doing hey Mike hey um what up
Mike Davis what's going on I don't think
we've ever answered this one
what's your least favorite episode of
Good Mythical Morning
least favorite episode do you have an
answer somebody yelled out ghost pepper
I mean the Carolina Reaper
wasn't it worse it was worse
well the the ones that people think the
Horseshoe people think the blind Taco
blind blood Taco butter I was like
what's a blind Taco I mean if I think
about like the physical effects of an
episode
um I don't even remember what it was it
wasn't the ghost pepper it was that
other one the Scorpion pepper where I
was in Good Mythical More I was lying on
the couch oh yeah um and I was just I
had lost the capacity for entertainment
like I was beyond being energized by
what was happening and I was just angry
and scared
and anxious
and uh that was bad and then of course
the longest lasting negative physical
effects was that um
the glass of vinegar
where it just led to like uh duo or
Danto with Smosh
yeah and it was that was horrible
um
that's the reason we ended up buying
them because I was so angry about that
yeah
it's like yeah don't cross me I'll buy
you I
to me you you you think it's the grape
nuts Vlog yeah that was torturous
uh
might see
answer my least favorite GM episodes of
the are the ones where it's like what
itch I think it would be if I could come
up with one
one that I was like really excited about
that them sucked because it's like yeah
the food stuff when we're miserable
afterward but it's really hard to point
to an episode that was like a complete
flop I mean you might not like some of
the guests and I'm not gonna throw any
guests under the bus so let's remove
those yeah like we've we've had a few
guests that like absolutely sucked yeah
right I think I might start a Reddit
thread where everybody can just talk
about which guests suck the most yeah I
mean we'll leave that for there
um
but it's you know it's a real credit to
the mythical crew that makes the show I
mean you've seen the evolution of the
show right it's like changing
over time
that like they know the show and us so
well that like there's they're setting
up parameters for the show to happen to
us you know it's a really interesting
thing that like this the the thing our
baby
is now something that we've basically
said all right we're entrusting you to
to raise our baby team and then bring
our baby to us and then and then see how
we react to it
oh it's my it's my baby's back or you've
gotten taller you know it's like sending
it off to boarding school it's this
weird it's this weird like
like being just as committed to Good
Mythical Morning as ever just as excited
about it as ever and knowing that like
there's ways that we can Infuse
ourselves into the show even more by
entrusting our team and stepping back
from the this the meticulations of
planning we've done that increasingly
year over year and I think it's really
having a positive impact on
the show because it gives us this an
increasingly more authentic
performance that's you know less and
less of a performance and more of just
an authentic experience of us behind
that desk you know so
I I can't find an episode where it was
like I was so excited and then it just
bombed or didn't come together because
like they
you know they they have all the right
places
that matter most there and you know so
it's we can kind of
mess around with it and I actually think
that so the cliche answer I always give
is who you like
but people ask the inverse like what's
your favorite episode and I'm always
like the next one because we do but what
that it's just like
we are excited about where the show's
going you know we're excited about the
things that we can do this that desk
that set that environment is a
playground for us and that's another
part of what we've been talking about in
realizing hey
what we've built together how can we
take more advantage of it creatively to
continue to push boundaries I mean
continue to eat stuff yes
we're going to keep eating stuff on good
mythical morning and we're going to keep
doing other things too you know uh it it
because it needs to be fun for us it
needs to be fun for the team that's
making it with us and blindsiding us
with it a lot of times right yeah and
you know I think that
some of our this wouldn't be a least
favorite it's like when am I the most
I'm actually changing the way I think
about this now like
you've we've talked about this before on
your biscuits when we try something that
we think is creatively ambitious or we
do something that isn't us just eating
something and then it performs at like
half the views because that's the way
the internet works but I know that's not
how you guys feel about it uh because
you're very vocal when you do
like watching us take a creative risk
and do something different and not only
because you watch many of you watch
every episode or most episodes and
therefore you're not just like I'm just
coming in for this one and I'm coming in
for this one
um so we actually have you in mind more
often than it may seem like sometimes
and again that's that sort of like well
this has got to be a business that
supports the team but this is also a
show that is for us and for you and for
our collective experience so we're going
to keep trying those things and we're
not going to be surprised or
disappointed if some of those things
that may require more effort or more
creativity or more time from the team
don't get as much of as many views as
it's just sitting down and trying every
flavor of a Hot Pocket
um but we'll continue to try to make
trying every flavor of a Hot Pocket as
uh entertaining and informative because
these things matter right right right
today we are eating another block of
Velveeta cheese
let's just do that for a month to turn
that question back on you Mike do you
have a least favorite episode of GMM I
do okay
wait probably the Horseshoe the horse
one yeah sorry it was a little boring
are you are you
ah I was bored I almost died I didn't
have anything to do
it's like what am I doing here
I don't think I should do anything are
you like are you a horse guy
okay yeah I know it makes me feel yeah
better or worse that he's not a horse
guy who's just bored with it
whole level of level of murder that you
just didn't get
yeah horse humor horse humor equine
yeah yeah some of some of them some of
them aren't for everybody yeah right it
didn't turn out how I thought it would
turn out yeah
yeah
you you saw my anxiety on full display
in that video boy see it's it it's
important for other reasons it's
important to be bored sometimes by our
show I had to take down all my posters
of horses that I have up around my house
Like Jesse was like why is all why are
all the horses in our Decor coming down
she loves horse decor
it's kind of her specialty
we're we're working on a um Thanksgiving
episode that you were going to hate
awesome
it doesn't involve horses but turkey but
you will be bored
yeah so don't miss it
won't
okay
[Applause]
uh the last question I'm not 100 sure is
Abigail Naylor here
oh gee we're gonna have to toss that
microphone you're way back there
way back there
we just got the yellow card
the yellow card yeah
um
this better be a good one if this is the
last one it is uh so as okay they're
right there sorry I'm late hello Abigail
hi so you had a question about
friendship what advice would you give to
us for maintaining such a meaningful
relationship with each other for the
many years to come yes that is my
question this is my my lifelong best
friend well like 11 years since we've
been no that's nothing so no yeah we got
a long way to go to compete but um
that's just a she's just like everything
to me I moved to a new state from North
Carolina moved to Louisiana with her I
knew no one as a little little 11 year
old girl
and like she was the first person I met
the very first week I moved to Louisiana
and she's just like if you know me you
know her if you know her you know me so
I just wanted to get y'all's advice
because y'all have such a great lifelong
relationship friendship so yeah that's
just my cleries so yeah
and what's your friend's name
[Applause]
Miss Miss Clarice
like silence
he hasn't seen it we we actually both
had the first same name we're both
Abigail but she does by Clarice so yeah
that makes it simpler okay I'm glad you
knew her name yes I learned that a
couple days ago because that I was gonna
say that's the that's the good first
step to Friendship
having the same name also helps that too
she didn't tell me that until like two
weeks after we knew each other she's
like oh my name's Abigail by the way I
was like that's
good information to have please
two weeks to find out her name
all right we got to give some we got to
give some some good advice here it's the
last question
um
well you know we've answered this we
have answered this question but we
wanted to
talk about it again
uh friendship
I friendship is not easy no you know
um you know I I'll I'll sing a lot guys
because I'm I'm a guy and I taught to
guys about friendships sometimes and it
uh
they're like well it's tough for guys
sometimes we're guys we have an
extraordinary friendship there's like
lots of there's a lot wrapped up into it
you know so there's there's a lot at
play here in some ways
like friendship or even best friendship
is an inadequate description of the
nature of our relationship yeah I mean
so so we are best friends
but when you're that and you're also
business partners and you're you're
your performers who a Cornerstone of
your performance is friendship
like I mean there could be some
there's some unique challenges for us
because it's
there's a lot wrapped up in it right uh
it it's certainly very important to us
to actually be friends because
we care about each other right but also
but and then secondarily because
this doesn't work if we're not actually
friends like that would really suck
right right you're saying that if you
make your relationship the product and
then the relationship is over
that is a big problem yeah we've never
seen that happen before
um
the um it's interesting somebody sent me
something recently that talked about how
the number of friends in people's lives
decreased dramatically
because of the pandemic
and specifically
a number of close friends I thought you
were going to say because of children
which is also a you know children will
kill friendships no but specifically
because of the social dynamics oh my
gosh the social dialogue of that the way
that things changed with the pandemic uh
there isn't I would say an alarming
percentage of people who do not have one
close friend like that has increased but
the number of and this is something that
has just been moving in that direction
culturally for a really long time so I
do think it's more important than ever I
one of the ways that we have answered
this question in the past
we always talk about communication I
want to come back to communication
because one of the things that I've said
and then we've talked we talked about
this recently on our own
is the way we would answer this question
on
um one of the tours
I think it was maybe Blake Creek or
whatever because there was a question
about friendship that would come up a
lot and we would talk about how having
something that you're a common goal
was key to a long friendship and the
fact that
we
were building something together and so
you've got this baby that you shared
together in the same way that like a
marriage may have kids
you pointed out which I agree with and
why I think that that is somewhat true
and I do think it's actually true
because for a lot of the reasons that
we're saying there's a lot of things at
stake and there's also a lot of things
that bring us back into each other's
lives because both of us tend to
kind of I mean you're more extroverted
than me but in a lot of ways we can go a
pretty long period of time without
having meaningful interactions with with
somebody because we have so many things
going on and there's a lot of people
maybe back home in North Carolina that
we're good friends with us that we're
just not the greatest at staying in
touch with people
um or initiating and maintaining those
long distance friendships so one of the
things we're thrown into each other's
worlds over and over again all the time
we're constantly in each other's world
so that that's one of the things right
so there's no out of sight out of mind
that's never going to happen with us
right but you kind of pointed out the
inadequacy in that
um analogy because the negative way of
seeing that is you would say that if it
were a marriage and people were just in
the marriage because of the kids then
the day that the kids leave
the marriage is over and that happens
all too often
and you made the point that well
that's only part of the answer and
probably not even the most important
part of the answer the answer is the
Friendship is valuable because the
Friendship is valuable and the
friendship uh remains and is important
because of the value that the Friendship
brings not because of the thing that you
guys are building together and the way
it benefits from your friendship if that
makes sense
yeah I think
definitely when you know it's when we're
both excited and going after the same
thing and we're like in this like
especially if we're in like a creative
flow it's very exhilarating to be there
with your lifelong best friend and to
say we're we're going after this thing
we're making this thing we're
and it's
it's kind of a magical Synergy it does
feel great and it does edify me and I
think our connection but there's yeah
there's also that personal side to it
that's like yeah but we're also actually
friends I'm restating what you're saying
in other words that and I think this is
kind of where our answer is is that
it takes a lot of work to maintain a a
relationship
you know and for it I thought I think
it's very important that we have given
ourselves permission to say
this is
we're committed to this and it requires
work and there's times when it's not
going as well as other times and given
ourselves and each other permission to
express our needs in the Friendship is
something that
uh I think we're still learning right
yeah I mean we're still growing as
individuals we're like we talked about
earlier like getting in touch with your
emotions understanding that there's a
lot more of those out there that can be
a part of your experience like that it's
a it's a similar experience of like
knowing how to apply
the principles of relationship to our to
a friendship because you think well you
can fall into this trap that like
friends should just be friends because
it's easy you know like you don't make
friends your closest friends are people
that like
you just find yourselves hanging out
with and having a good time with oh I
find myself liking this person but
that's not you know a friendship is not
going to thrive long term if you don't
give yourself permission to say no this
is a relationship that needs that
requires work and energy and if you're
and a big part of that is being
vulnerable to say hey in this particular
time
I have a need that's not being met
that in our friendship or vice versa and
so and we've had those conversations and
I you know I I think that's something
that we haven't shared publicly we just
say we leave it at communication but I
think that's a little more specific
version of that same
thing because it's easy to say we just
go you just got to communicate you got
to talk things out but like
even after all these years when you find
that like if you have a certain need in
the Friendship that's not being met it's
a hard thing to say you know that's it's
a very vulnerable moment right and then
on the other side of it though is this
you know
A Renewed connection and A Renewed bond
that I think we've been through that a
number of times yeah so this may seem
like a tautology or circular reasoning
or whatever you want to call it but the
best way to maintain a friendship long
term is to continue to be friends
right and it and don't expect it to be
easy and and understanding that it's a
commitment and I think the same thing
applies to relationships you know we
could really quickly transfer this into
marriage advice
um you know when we got into our
marriages
it was under very very specific
understanding and we were in a very
specific place in terms of our world
view and in that worldview divorce was
not really an option right
um now we are different people at this
point and I think that there are
legitimate reasons for relationships to
end and marriages to end
but I think that we still have to
approach our marriages as if divorce is
not an option
you know obviously there are
circumstances that could lead to that
but I think that you have to go in with
the level of commitment that like this
isn't going to be based on continual
feelings of romance and friendships are
not going to be based on continual
feelings of compatibility or this The
Vibes are always good
if that's what it's based on the moment
that that ends it's just like all right
I got more convenient people or whatever
it's something that's easier for me so I
think that that's where the
communication comes in the communication
is because things are when you when you
work on so many things together and
you're together all the time in the same
way that you get annoyed at your brother
or your sibling that's that's the kind
of relationship that we have
and so
understanding when that's beginning to
happen and knowing when conversations
are
required in order to kind of break
through that and move to the to the next
step has been really pivotal is that
good that's perfect it's more than
enough thank you
all right guys
you can always let us know what you
think using hashtag ear biscuits or you
can leave us a voicemail one eight eight
earpod one
thanks for joining us at mythicon we'll
talk at you next week
love ya
hey Ryan link my name is Carlin uh we're
driving back from mythicon and we just
wanted to say that uh seeing you guys go
up on stage and do uh what you guys have
always wanted to do with James and the
shame and uh seeing Charles so proud of
you guys and uh with the course uh
outcome snuggle baby like you guys
absolutely killed it so awesome to see
you guys doing what you want to do I
read link uh my name is Brett I've been
to mythical Beast a long time miss a con
was a blast you guys hit it out of the
park and it was everything I hoped it
would be I got to me Miss crew members
face to face which was so surreal your
guys's live performance and the the time
gate bit sent me over the [ __ ] Moon I
was dead laughing it meant so much to me
to to be here this weekend and to share
in the first ever mysticon so I just I
want to thank you guys wholeheartedly
the mythical crew Everybody working
behind the scenes keep being your
mythical selves
especially you DJ Elkhound snuggle baby
on YouTube James hi Rhett and Link also
known as James and the shame and DJ El
kelm snuggle baby I had a great time at
mythicon it was amazing and I just
wanted to let you guys know that this
year has been really just for me and my
husband we had a miscarriage and then to
follow up sales IVF Cycles but right
before mythicon I had another my fourth
cycle and the day after mythicon I found
out that I got a positive pregnancy test
so we're expecting and it just seems so
fitting with um snuggle baby 50th J name
just all magically came together so I
appreciate you guys and what you're up
to and thanks for just being your
mythical best
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best